like if you're doing something to get
money quick
and you're trying to like have longevity
usually that's not really how it works
you got to have some sort of passion or
some sort of like uh
care for what the passion like you're
into you're into fitness this is what
you do this is not like you're not like
some
some like rich dude who decided oh
there's good money in supplements right
let me start my own supplement line
right right
or i'm an influencer let me start my own
protein powder just because
hey big bro how do i start a line i'm
like why well if i like what if you got
to ask me that [ __ ] you ain't cut out
for this [ __ ] like there's people
there's producers and there's consumers
in this world you know what i'm saying
producers
figure out like you want something like
when i started the supplement game
i never took supplements all my life
until i started getting like worn down
i'm training so many people i ain't got
no energy
tried like a fat burner pre-workout
whatever that she gave me energy but it
gave me like weird side effects bro just
itchy arms all that [ __ ] alanine so i go
and i started taking pictures of every
supplement label
after work long as uh days
i'm falling asleep every night with my
computer on my my laptop on my chest
researching looking up these ingredients
trying to identify
what is it that gives me the energy
what is it that gives me these side
effects i didn't like
can this work without that you know what
i'm saying then i start ordering [ __ ]
from china cheap [ __ ] testing on myself
that's how i started this [ __ ] right so
you would make your own stuff i'm a
producer right like you're a producer
you know what i'm saying so
but most of the world are consumers it's
a small amount of people providing goods
and services
and most people need they need somebody
to provide it so they can buy it and
that's fine that's how the world is i
was explaining that to my son
because he was like
he was talking about like kids at school
like they're kind of simple i like look
son don't look at it like that this is
the normal order of things the natural
order of things
most people are that are that and that's
fine there's no knock to them that's
just how it is
it's very people got to understand this
the essence of life of all biological
life on this planet is to be lazy is
efficiency to not do much you know what
i'm saying i'm gonna sit still till i'm
hungry
i'm hungry and i'm gonna go get some
food you know what i'm saying
a lion we look at them as so badass
right the [ __ ] just chill like
they women go hunting
oh you got it all right move get out get
out the [ __ ] way i'm eating first you
know what i'm saying
that's the nature the natural order of
things people are not designed to be
hustling
people design a chill to relax to rest
you know what i mean so
there's a few weirdos that like to do a
lot of [ __ ] you know what i'm saying and
we as we're in the animal kingdom but
we're a little bit different because we
got these [ __ ] robust cerebral cortex
which the other animals don't so we have
imagination
empathy we can remember things we got
language so we got all these different
ways of like recording information and
passing it down and we learn more pass
it down learn more so we know that we
can and
we know we can do certain things that
are that may seem difficult to do but it
gives us pleasure you know